first off yeah if you're watching this
and you're from disney
don't strike the channel please just
send me a message on twitter
i'll take the video down i know that's
probably not going to happen yet but
i swear on the child's life i'll just
remove it
i love you mickey anyway this is the
heavy spoiler show i'm your host paul
and this video we're breaking down the
apparent plot leaks for the mandalorian
season 2 episode 5. now else i can't
confirm these for definite until the
episode airs on friday
these leaks come from multiple sources
and all seem to line up
hence why i'm doing the video take them
with a pinch of salt but you should know
pretty shortly whether they're true or
not
i'm taking a big gamble here dropping
them so closely to the release date
but but dude bro trust me now obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here and
we'll be revealing the child's name
it's apparent origin story and what
happens with ahsoka
if they're true then these are very very
big leaks
so this is your last chance to back out
anyway without the way thank you for
clicking this
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
episode 5 is going to be called the jedi
and it will have a run time of about 58
minutes
making it the longest mandalorian
episode ever
it's for a good reason too as we very
much get a lot of things filled in
which i think you'll enjoy as we go
through the breakdown
according to the leaks we pick up on
corvus with ahsoka fighting with her to
lightsabers she's combating several
armed forces carrying blasters
and chops them up amongst the trees
these have invaded kaladin
and ahsoka is trying to take it back but
there are a large number of soldiers in
it
so it's a bit difficult for her to swarm
them all at once
the lightsabers are apparently white and
it's meant to be a
big entrance for the first time that we
get these weapons in the show
now according to the leaks ahsoka looks
exactly how you'd imagine her
rosario dawson is meant to come across
as the best cosplayer in the world
and she's complete with ahsoka's orange
skin as well as some bright blue contact
lenses
and the jedi cloak that she wears over
her head
we don't know ahsoka's full mission here
but shortly after she confronts the
leader of the city who is a woman known
as the magistrate
apparently the magistrate wants to
execute the citizens of caledon
and she sort of becomes the big bad of
this episode that leads into
other things which we'll talk about in
just a bit osaka gives her one day to
surrender
otherwise she'll return and she then
goes back to the forest
now this is where mano comes in and he's
of course trying to track down the
character
he lands in kaladin and comes face to
face with the magistrate
who wants him to kill ahsoka the
magistrate has some best score that she
wants to give him as a means of payment
and as we know from the first episode
this is extremely rare within the galaxy
and it's very sought after now mano then
accepts the job
hunts down ahsoka and the pair fight it
out it's not meant to be
a massive scene according to the plot
leaks but mano manages to stop things
from escalating further
by bringing up bokeh tan who of course
had a friendship with ahsoka
over the years and many many star wars
series
now i really like how this is all sort
of tied together
and if it's true it does make sense to
do all this
this is when the child is brought into
it and ahsoka recognizes him as being
from the same species as yoda
apparently yoda himself is actually name
dropped in this episode
so the series is tying into the grand
overall plot of the saga
and it's from here that we really get
the backstory of the child's past
though ahsoka doesn't know him directly
she's able to dive into his mind and
through the force
she learns of his true name which is
drunk drumroll please dramul
yes that's right grogu now i've only
seen this written down so i'm not sure
if it's pronounced grogu or grogu
but that is apparently the child's name
his entire backstory is then given
which delves in into his origins back
back in the good old days of the jedi
now grogu was
actually trained as a jedi on coruscant
during the clone wars
but after the empire rose to power he
was hidden away
apparently someone took him but that's
about as far as we get and ahsoka
isn't able to find out any extra
information beyond that
as their connection cuts off now whilst
this isn't in the leaks
you know his memory sort of blanking
this out
is likely the time that the empire came
after him ahsoka is meant to say that
his memory becomes dark
and therefore we can kind of take from
that that it could be the dark side
surrounding him
as we know from episode 4 the imperial
forces were trying to figure out how to
clone four sensitive beings
but this had been failing thus they'd
been harvesting the blood of the child
in order to pass along his midichlorians
and revive emperor palpatine so that he
could once more rule over the galaxy
this is of course how the character was
able to duplicate himself
and snoke and whilst we don't have
anything beyond this
it does seem that palps might have
become aware of the child
whilst he wasn't core sent again none of
this was mentioned in the leaks
it's just me theorizing how the empire
learned about him
yoda's species on the whole are very
much at one with the force
so it makes sense that pulps would be
keeping an eye on him now they team up
to take down the magistrate
and the episode is meant to slot very
much into the usual mandalorian
aesthetic from this point onwards
you know how it goes they attack
somewhere there's a cool little action
scene
they learn a bit more information rinse
and repeat
and the person that they learn
information from it's obviously going to
be the magistrate
and with mando ahsoka manages to capture
her
we discover what ahsoka has been doing
this entire time
and it's revealed that she's actually
after grand admiral thrawn
case you don't know drawn ties massively
into the expanded universe
and fans of the comics and books that
were printed after the original trilogy
will instantly recognize his name thrawn
was a male shish
with striking blue skin red eyes
and very prominent cheekbones he was
known for his brilliant strategic mind
and ruthlessness
and if rumors of a spin-off star wars
show are true
then having bone ahsoka team up to take
him down
i think that's going to be amazing they
of course need a villain
and it makes perfect sense to set up
thrawn here so they can go off and fight
him in other properties
anyway we did theorize that ahsoka would
train the child
but this isn't the case and instead she
says that she has to go after thrawn
this leads to mando being given the
location of a jedi temple
which he'll be able to take grogu to in
order to learn more about the ins and
outs of his past
that's pretty much the main plot point
i've heard and again take these with a
pinch of salt for now
as i can't verify them until the episode
airs on friday
some of this stuff sounds a bit iffy to
me and i'm not a massive fan of doing
plot leaks in general just
as they can lead to trouble with the
channel and also if they're untrue
i look a bit stupid however like i said
these come from multiple sources and
they all line up
so i thought i'd just tell you what i'd
heard and we will see later in the week
i think if you're watching this video
then you'll be watching the show on
friday anyway
so i don't know how many issues it would
cause for disney
but if you work for the company and want
me to take the video down
just hit me up on my twitter and i'll
remove it after we verify that
you're not just lying because you hate
spoilers anyway
with leaks like this i think even if
people know the plot
they tend not to know if they're legit
so they watch this stuff anyway
but any issues yeah it's cool now as for
the episode itself
i think that it sounds amazing and
reading these
i had my jaw on the floor at some points
i'm a bit unsure over the child's name
but grogu is actually something that was
floating around
all the way back in 2019 it was
originally posted on star wars leaks
and then removed shortly after which
only tends to happen when things are
legit
but again this seems to line up so i
friday isn't too long away and we'll see
then i'm just
i'm just glad we're getting ahsoka
either way and
i think she'll definitely be appearing
in this week's entry
so at least we'll definitely get one
thing right and people will be like
the spoils they were they were true all
of them
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leaks whether you think
they're true or not and
what else you want to see if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 4 which will be
linked at the end
we go over the entire plot and things
you missed so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november so make
sure you get involved if you want to
support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
just here